be watching that movie for about ten
times so every time I would have
freshman I watched the movie when I was
growing up Bill Gates was my hero
oh come on yes rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message have
heroes over you Jack Ma also if you want
to let Jack and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 254
confident series where every day for the
next two hundred and fifty four days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
the people who did the bottom should
believe in the model and I believe what
I do who are your heroes who are my
heroes
well I got my star in my dream from
America 2 for 15 years ago when I came
to America when I visited Silicon Valley
I saw sounding in the evening that the
road it was full of cars all the
buildings was lights that's the passion
and I went the the hero
I had is Forrest Gump 14 years ago and I
watch the choices you know he's a
fictional character though you did like
that guy I'd be watching that movie for
about 10 times every time I went
frustrate I watch the movie and I watch
movie before I came here again were you
know for the for coming to the New York
so what I'll watch the movie again and
telling me that no matter whatever
changed you are you and I'm student guy
15 years ago
no I only earned like a $20 a mouth and
today I can do that much you know
it's order now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for a question of the day I want to know
who is the hero that you have learned
the most from leave your answers in the
comments below
I mean Bruce Lee was a huge childhood
hero running through like a childhood
theme here all running through my
adolescence just because Bruce Lee he
was loved by all communities you know
like there's plenty of Asian people that
are in pop culture they're just loved by
the Asian community but he was one of
the only ones that was globally loved by
everyone so I always looked up to that
kind of idea that like there's that us
Asians have the capacity to actually be
part of popular culture and an influence
not outside not just our own culture
there were probably a lot of people who
can who can run Microsoft into a
reasonable job when I was growing up
Bill Gates was my hero
oh come on yes he's like Darth Vader
he's not he's not Luke Skywalker he's
the bad guy no he is not
Bill Gates ran one of the most
mission-driven companies that I can
think of right and you know right now I
think Microsoft is their mission is less
focused than it used to be but when I
was thinking about you know what would I
want it to be when when I grew up you
know Microsoft I thought had it had a
great mission put a computer on on every
desktop and in every office right or
maybe was every desktop and every call
but and you know I mean there were
companies that define themselves by a
way of doing things right I mean there's
them like the HP way that I was talking
about and there were companies that
define themselves by making a concrete
change in the world and you know
Microsoft did that and like I have a
huge amount of respect for him for doing
that he pushed them and it was an
incredibly inspiring company during the
time that he was doing that I think that
there they still are doing a lot of
things but I think that they've lost
some of the focus and I don't know I
mean I think he's like one of the one of
the greatest visionaries that our that
our industry has ever had
you truly adore your parents don't you I
love my parents just so much mate I you
know like my mom how'd you be you know I
was born on her birth
they and and all she ever did was just
love me and prop me up and get me back
out in there and my dad just the legend
of the universe when I was the tiniest
little kid Andrew and look up at my dad
and you know he was like larger than
life he was just like this action hero
he was everything I wanted to be and all
I've done in my life is following his
footsteps mimic him and try to be him
and nowadays I just try to make him
proud night
yeah I love my parents like like nothing
else it's just they are everything to me
absolutely everything in the day that my
mum the went was a Dale awesome al
awesome plus something really big raise
your standard Apple at the cool it's
core value is that we believe that
people with passion not one drop of
myself work depends on Europe it's
something serene if you want more Jack
Ma check out the Jack Ma motivation
video that I did I think you'll enjoy
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I didn't I have a rich father not
from you know well-educated I said I
tried three times for University all
filled